a lot of Twitter action going on right
now guy asking along the same subject
several other people did what do you
think of this fast-food strike well let
me kind of help you with that if you
worked for me and you're not a part of a
union which gives you legal protection
and you go on strike I'm going to fire
you instantaneously instantly I'll put
your little fry fry and butt in the
street so here's what you get you don't
get $15 you get to zero by now why would
I take that harsh stand these are young
people now that listen situation what
these are our little entitled brats you
think you're entitled to tell someone
who owns a business what they have to
pay you you negotiated the rate when you
went to work there if you don't like the
rate go to work somewhere else well I
can't find anything else
proof that you're worth what you're
being paid you little twit if you're
Worth's a dad-blame much go prove it
it's not fair fair is a thing that has
the tilt awhirl and a ferris wheel at it
there is no fair kiddo these little
whiny snotty nosed socialists entitled
brats I mean you just want to smack them
silly so what you deserve if you go on
strike at fast food is to have your
little socialist liberal but fired
that's what you deserve you negotiated a
deal you do not have rights in this
culture to demand and to tell other
people what they will pay you you don't
have that right you don't have that
legal right you have no moral standing
you have no economic right you are not
bringing economic value whining is not
economic value bitching and moaning is
not economic value well now we're a
movement yeah you are definitely a
in a bowel movement there is no question
about it the biggest twerps in our
culture right now are in the middle of
this thing you guys are an embarrassment
to America it's ridiculous you want to
make more money go get a job that pays
more money hmm
why is that hard I've made two dollars
an hour I've made $1 an hour I've made
$3 an hour and I've made millions of
dollars and in every case I earned it
it was the deal quit being a little
spoiled child this week I was sitting
with one of our executives doing a
review of his work over the last year
and he said it came to one things we do
it annually as we look at their we
review their compensation now we don't
pay you more just because you've been
here another year we pay you more
because that's what that position is
worth in the marketplace and or the
particular things you bring to the
position or worth but that is something
you and I discuss this person did not
sit down and say I'm going to go on
strike if you don't pay me more or I'm
going to quit if you don't pay me more
either one of those would have resulted
in that being their last day but they
did say hey look here's what I make and
here's two different compensation
surveys that show that I'm not at the
highest end I'm not even in the middle
and I think my work is at the highest
end I said you know what you're right
your work is at the highest end and so
we're going to adjust this and I
regained my $5,000 raise that's pretty
good they you know why they earned it he
didn't come in expecting to get paid
more just because that's fair
oh you would you unbelievable sissies
this is crazy who raised you people you
are worth what you negotiate or what
that position pays in his marketplace
and guess what
doctors make more than people
dig ditches veterinarians make more than
fast-food workers a they have more
knowledge that is a being applied in the
marketplace be they've got tons of
education that prove that see the
marketplace is simply willing to pay
them for that and they chose based on
the marketplaces the conversation to go
into that field you chose to be a
whopper flopper and you chose that and
you knew what the pay was when you chose
it there's no shame in being a whopper
flopper I've done work that was a lot
worse and that I got paid a lot less for
there's no shame in that at all the
shame is when you expect somehow just
because you show up and you're special
that you breathe air that you're do more
money you're not special
you're not special you're sweet you're
pitiful you're ignorant but you're not
special now there is nothing wrong good
people do good work if fast-food
restaurants I have no issue with someone
working a fast-food restaurant but if
you walk in there and the guy says I'm
gonna pay you 20 dollars an hour you say
I'll take the job I'm going to pay you
$15 an hour I'm going to take the job
I'm going to pay you $7 an hour I'm
going to take the job great you took the
job you just made the decision at any
point in the conversation at any point
in your employment if that is not enough
money and you don't think that is a
quote fair wage for that you have the
opportunity to go into the marketplace
and prove it by getting another job I'm
worth more than that why because you're
special you entitled little socialist
liberal twit you are not special you get
the opportunity to work and prove your
worth it's that simple
people who can do web programming make
more than a lot of people who can't
hello people who write books make more
than a lot of people who can't people
who work on cars make more than a lot of
people who can't and
should be able to but you do not at any
point in the conversation have the right
to come in and say because it's fair I
demand that you pay me more you just
don't have that right you have the right
to vote with your feet I was working for
a company corporate America one time
people were stupid I was a young guy I
made really good money working for them
and they wanted to move me over to
another project because I had done such
a good job they were going to give me a
promotion go work on another project
only the promotion I'm working on the
other project involved less pay and I've
got guys you know understand I'm gonna
get less pay for more work because I've
done a good job at the other place well
that's what we want you to do well I'm
not going to do that I'll stay over here
well you're not really giving you a
choice you have to go over there no I
don't have to go over there this is
America baby I can go somewhere else and
I quit I have the right to leave if I
don't like the way I'm being treated the
way I'm being paid but I do not have the
right to make that company pay me more
because I'm special
you're a whopper flopper you are not
special this is the Dave Ramsey show